two miles in here using the new pure
boost raw running cheese from adidas
hey there Bioneers excuse my disheveled
appearance and shaven hair a mess life
has still been busy as I was saying
before I'm moving house and working on
doing some upgrades to the site and the
YouTube channel so I haven't been able
to record as many videos as I'd like and
when I do I look like this I also look
like this because I have been running as
you will know from that brief
introduction at the start of this video
and so I want to talk a little bit about
that a lot of people are under the
impression the running of particularly
steady-state to cardio like running long
distances is bad for muscle mass and
hypertrophy and that can be true to some
extent but it's not necessarily true
allow me to explain so of course when
you run fast or long distance your body
is forced to take energy from elsewhere
other than the energy ATP stored in the
muscles and the glucose in the blood
this is why you kick into the aerobic
energy system which is where you start
breathing heavily and you start to
mobilize fat stores to use to supply
energy to the muscles to the brain and
to the lungs so you can continue to
exert yourself this is the most
efficient energy form but it's also the
slowest which is why we don't use it
when we're lifting weights or engaging
in spurts of intense exercise such as a
sprint so after you're burning fat and
that's the point for a lot of people
when they're doing steady-state cardio
they're trying to lose weight but if
you're trying to build muscle you
perhaps don't want to do that especially
as you can also end up
burning muscle and this is the bit I
want to talk about because the reason
you burn muscle partly when you do
steady-state cardio so I've been
trafficking here when you do
steady-state cardio
or any other form of exercise this
aerobic in nature is partly because you
deplete those glucose stores in your
blood and when that happens you produce
cortisol you may know this as the stress
hormone you produce cortisol instead of
serotonin serotonin is made from
tryptophan which is leftover in the
blood after the release of insulin comes
from your food particularly carbs and
that puts you in a good mood and also
satiates you which is why you can use
serotonin boosters as a way to diet so
anyways when you exercise and deplete
all your glucose you produce cortisol
the stress hormone in short your body
stressed because it's got no energy and
it's telling you hey man go and get some
food
this also triggers the release of gralen
the hunger hormone and myostatin and
myostatin is the one that we're
interested in here now the reason we're
interested in myostatin is because
myostatin is a protein that causes the
breakdown of muscle for energy in this
case and also body just to keep your
body in a more energy efficient state
because fast twitch muscle fiber is very
energy hungry and if you're in a
scenario where you don't have access to
food where you're often in a calorie
deficit it's not efficient to be
carrying large amounts of muscle around
with you this is dangerous
so Maya statins release it breaks down
muscle and this is a response to the
cortisol increase which comes from the
globe glucose and so that's why a lot of
people want to avoid cardio if they're
weightlifting
but they're missing the bigger picture
because actually if you do cardio and
steady-state cardio in particular not so
much high-intensity interval training
then you can increase the size of the
left ventricle in your heart this is the
part that takes filled up with
oxygenated blood ready to squeeze it and
pump it around your body when you engage
in steady-state cardio slow cardio such
as jogging you're able to train this
over time you can take in more and more
oxygenated blood to pump around your
body and thus your parasympathetic tone
improves and thus your resting heart
rate improves it's lower this results in
better sleep and lower stress because
your stress your fight-or-flight
response triggered by the
parasympathetic and the sympathetic
nervous systems that's linked very
closely to your breathing when you
breathe quickly in a stressed kind of
scenario you go into fight or flight
when you breathe in a slower more
relaxed state then you go into rest and
to digest and rest and digest is
essentially the anabolic to the
catabolic that is fight or flight
so in short training using steady-state
cardio or anything else that's going to
improve your parasympathetic tone your
resting heart rate will help you to be
more anabolic the rest of the time
because you'll be producing less
cortisol more serotonin and therefore
you'll be more anabolic therefore you'll
actually produce less mice that in
throughout the day and throughout your
life so while you might to burn a little
bit of muscle doing the cardio in the
short term in the long term it might
actually help you to build more muscle
like I said this doesn't work quite the
same high-intensity interval training
and so all the people who are saying
stop doing steady-state start doing
high-intensity interval training they
are being a little bit reactionary and
perhaps throwing the baby out with the
bathwater as it were because HIIT whilst
it's very useful for lots of things and
you should be doing it it doesn't it's
not the answer to everything the study
of state cardio also has a lot of other
great
benefits it's just you sleep so much
better when you've got that improved
resting heart rate be able to deliver
more oxygen and nutrients to your
muscles during rest and during workouts
meaning you can have better workouts and
more efficient recovery and in general
it's important to be fit and healthy so
you know a lot of people were focused
way to much on losing weight or building
muscle actually the primary concern
should be on being healthy because then
you'll have more energy then you'll have
a better mood you'll sleep better and as
a result and shaken as a result you'll
end up training more and getting better
results so yeah even if you're a
bodybuilder you should do steady-state
cardio and in fact most professional
bodybuilders do Annie did they know the
importance of keeping a healthy heart
especially as your body gets bigger and
heavier and for them especially if
they're going to be using certain
illicit substances and it's also a great
way to cut if you're going to be eating
huge amounts of protein taking in large
amounts of calories then you want to try
and avoid that being stored as fat as
far as possible and any kind of CV will
burn your fat stores first not the
muscle so if you even if you did a
little bit of muscle just do more
working out operating and more CV and
you'll have a better overall body
composition so yeah I hope you found
that helpful and/or interesting ideally
both that's what I was going for
basically
basically do steady-state cardio also
it's fun you get to explore new areas
and I'll be posting more about that in
future talking about how to get into
running and running shoes stuff like
that as well as all the usual stuff on
Fitness muscle building brain training
working online etc so please subscribe
and like this video if you enjoyed it
and stay tuned for much more higher
quality higher volume of videos that is
coming and I appreciate your support
very much so bye for now
this takes selfies to some kind of you
know I think but it's like you're
running with me